let's talk about the travel ban real
quick after the terrorist attacks in
London Donald Trump wasted no time using
it as an opportunity to Pat himself on
the back just like he did after the
Orlando shooting some time ago Donald
Trump tweeting we need to be smart
vigilant and tough we need the courts to
give us back our rights we need the
travel ban as an extra level of safety
he sent another tweet about the travel
ban saying quote whatever the United
States can do to help out in London in
the UK we will be there we are with you
god bless but the travel ban that's the
first priority so after the attack all
of a sudden the number one thing is we
need the travel ban Trump was right all
along
bla bla bla the problem is it supposedly
wasn't a travel ban Donald Trump may
have shot himself in the foot here he
says we need the travel ban yet his
administration has denied for a long
time that it is a travel ban one other
tweet I believe that we have that Donald
Trump sent about the travel ban so this
is the first one that which we showed
travel ban we need is an extra level of
safety and then we have one other tweet
I believe about the travel ban that's
right we need a travel ban for certain
dangerous countries not some politically
correct term that won't help us protect
our people Trump himself previously
denied that it was a travel ban White
House lawyers have just asked the
Supreme Court to hear the case it has
been ruled by lower courts to be
unconstitutional because it
discriminates based on religion and for
White House lawyers a big part of
defending this was saying it's not
actually a ban this is a disaster for
Trump isn't it yeah it's the latest
instance of his tweeting being because
of him to shoot himself in the foot on
this one I mean completely unforced
error and I know his own team has to get
behind him and have these interventions
to try to get him off of Twitter right
and you know internet addiction is a
real thing but you don't typically
associated among 70 year old billionaire
with who happened to be President of the
United States
the ACLU tweeted about this responding
to Donald Trump's tweet saying glad we
both agree the ban is a ban so this is
really sort of like the main issue
around
admitting that it's a travel ban what's
in the ban itself is not all that
matters the previous rulings on Trump's
travel bans have said the context in
which the legislation is created matters
and as a result we can consider what
Donald Trump said during rallies about
his intent when it comes to this travel
ban we can say we can look at what
Donald Trump has said in different
venues there's no doubt courts have made
a clear path that Donald Trump tweeting
multiple times that really the goal of
this is to be a travel ban that can be
considered by courts when determining
the true goal of this ban it's really no
wonder to why he's lost and had to
settle so many cases yeah remember the
Trump University lawsuit he attacked the
judge for being a mexican-american
course the guy was from Indiana but
couldn't help himself
good just can't control himself it he
genuinely appears to not be able to
control himself on Twitter and a lot of
people on our reddit discussion forum
are talking about this and other Twitter
related goofs that have taken place join
us there david pakman.com slash reddit
today's program is made possible in part
by Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8,000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30 day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com
forward slash TDP s